hello welcome to another episode of Q&A
about history of Science and
Technology let's see looks like we have
a bunch of
questions uh saved up here one from eron
can I talk about the history of gazettes
I.E the recording of official
information well I can tell you a little
bit about what I know um I think
uh that the
idea of sort
of recording in some tangible form
information about what's happening in a
city
State whatever else I mean that was kind
of pioneered I think in Antiquity in in
Babylon maybe in Egypt uh I think what
one sees there is a lot of okay what
does one see one sees lots of kind of
contracts between people saying you know
you'll pay me and I will deliver barley
to you within three months or something
like that those are little clay tablets
with with can form uh sort of markings
from from uh certainly 1500 BC or
probably earlier than that um there's
also kind of the official sort of
description of the king achieved this
and that and the other and uh you know
the the the big kind of um uh sort of
governmental displays of you know I am
so and so King of Kings etc etc etc um
and uh the the long list of the
achievements of the king you know I took
over this territory I crushed my enemies
whatever else um I think my impression
is that in by Roman times there were
there was a fair amount of information
that was being collected about from
typically Tax Collectors going out to
the Empire so to speak and I think that
was that ended up getting stored there
were definite places where where that
kind of information was stored um I
don't know if on tablets or papyri or
whatever I think I think not much of
that survives uh there certainly were
things like official price lists in the
Roman Empire things like this that did
survive um I don't think that the you
know who paid what for to whom
necessarily survived I know that the
kind of classic place where that was the
origin of kind of Statistics properties
of the state so to speak was a thing
during much much later in the 1600s in
England uh guy called John Grant I think
gr Grant
um produced this thing called the bills
of
mortality uh rather grimly during the
Black Death probably 1665 I would guess
um in London was uh this is you know
kind of a summary for the city of you
know who died how in this particular
week and that um that was an early
example of kind of a a uh delivery of a
kind of a a global piece of information
about
uh about what was going on I think in
terms of sort of the collection of
information um and its organization I
mean another famous example of this this
is already the 1800s was um uh John
Playfair I think um was uh uh produced
this thing what was it statistical brevy
maybe was it's a book which has pretty
good visual
representations of the time series
effectively of what amounts to what we
would Now call GDP of countries and
things like this that's that's much
later um I think that the idea of
producing for example well okay the the
the question of when do people start
doing
censuses well there clearly were
censuses from long ago there were there
were censuses in in Antiquity in Roman
times and so on certainly
in um uh for somebody like me growing up
in England you always leared about the
Doomsday Book from just after 1066 when
the Norman conquest of England happened
um they Somebody went around and tried
to inventory what do we just conquer and
uh uh produce this um uh this kind of
um uh this the summary of what were all
the towns and and Villages and so on in
the countryside and and even down to
what houses there were and you know
people nowadays are are proud that you
know their Village has was recorded in
the Doomsday Book from whatever it is
1068 or something and uh you know
perhaps even their house is marked there
a thing that was on the site of their
house was marked there and so on so
certainly that that kind of thing
existed um the idea that one would use
uh the the kind of um uh you know the
census was I think largely collected for
in most places for purposes of Taxation
or for purposes of okay you know you
have X number of people there you should
send this number of people to be part of
the army or something like this um I
think when the when the US was was
founded the kind of idea that the census
would be sort of a central part of the
way the government was set up and and
defined and how many representatives
came from different places I think that
that was a new idea I'm not sure um the
uh to to base representation so to speak
on the results of a census um certainly
uh
around well
by by that time
um well there
were I don't know what happened for
example in France and the time of
Napoleon and so on Napoleon was very
organized fellow among among all sorts
of other things but uh you know set up a
lot of kind of structures that probably
many of which still survive today that
um were kind of census like things and I
I I don't know I would strongly suspect
that there were uh there was pretty
organized by that point in in places
like France um so that's that's that's
kind of what I what I know I think the
concept that the census is public
information that's a pretty us Centric
concept I think at least in its
origination the idea that it's you know
I think it comes with the government you
know by the people for the people type
thing that okay government produced
documentation becomes in the public
domain for the public I mean I know when
as as collectors of lots of data about
countries it's sometimes been a
challenge for us as we collect data for
for our knowledge base
uh you know that's probably a decade ago
I remember hearing from the uh European
analogue of the FAA the FAA distributes
certain kinds of data freely as a
government organization in the US but
the an analogous organizations in Europe
are like well you know we don't have the
same setup as as the US you know we're
trying to make money from our data type
thing where you know that's that's what
we do as a government kind of thing
rather than it's kind of by the people
for the people typee thing where all of
that government data is is freely
available that's that's a that seems to
be a particularly us Centric idea uh
same is true in England for example a um
uh things like the maps the so-call
Ordinance survey mapping of the country
was absolutely not freely available in
fact U when open street map Steve Coast
who was a former intern of ours who
ended up creating open street map his
original goal was sort of free the maps
that the US the the UK government
claimed were Crown copyright kinds of
data um and eventually the the sort of
the maps were effectively reverse
engineered and that's what gave us open
street map which is very widely used as
kind of a a mapping foundation for
mapping we certainly use it in wol
language and wol alfha and so on um but
that was uh so so you know the
convention the the idea of what was the
property of the government and what was
sort of for the people uh different in
different places and and the US was very
very much on the for the people type
type thing so a few things to to say
about that I would say that the um uh in
terms
of you know usually information gets
collected by governments and things when
there's a an obvious kind of tax or
other related purpose in doing that
although somehow the US government
particularly has been particularly big
on just collect data on all kinds of
things and and uh you know particularly
in the early days of w malfa back um
well before we released W malfa in 2009
and in a few years after that as we were
probing more and more different sources
of data it was pretty common for us to
find US government uh data collection
operations where people would say to us
thank you for asking for this data we've
been collecting it for a hundred years
and almost nobody ever asked ask for
this data um and uh so there's there's a
lot of that that's gone on and it's I
suppose it's sort of interesting that
there's a lot of data that there'll be a
Time series that goes back to let's say
1970 there's a whole bunch that go back
to about 1970 I think that must have
been a time uh for example when it comes
to economic data financial data and so
on that must have been a time when
things got computerized to the point
where sort of there's there's surviving
data that's been kept
to give you examples of other kinds of
data like in financial data there are
stock prices and the stock prices have
been published in the newspapers since
well certainly sometime in the by by the
late 1800s that was happening probably
earlier than that as well but the the
sort of digitizing all of that stuff and
lining it up and figuring out oh this
company with this ticker symbol then
turned into this thing now that's been
very thinly done not a lot of that has
been done the the times when that has
been done and people consider it quite
valuable data is by some quantiative
finance places where their sort of
fundamental principle is history repeats
and you know if one saw some pattern of
stock prices back in 1912 or something
that was you know the the the grain
price went up and the and the pig price
went down and whatever else it is that
by golly in some sort
of modified form that same thing will
repeat today so it's really useful to
have even that very distant
data let's see question from Jamie
here uh why are some older coins or
bills worth more than the original face
value well I guess it's because people
there is a certain gravity that comes
with age one likes to think of that for
people too um I think when I got to a
certain age I could rightfully call call
myself an antique so to speak um you
know I think the thing that's always
interesting about old stuff versus new
stuff is let's say old furniture for
instance uh people say oh it's wonderful
I I think there is a sense in which yes
it was Better Built and built in a more
artisanal way in the past and built with
better materials and so on but there's
also another phenomenon which is the
stuff that's junk gets thrown away the
stuff that's good survives and so and
people keep it and so the the things
that have sort of survived 200 years
it's like somebody had to bother to keep
it for 200 years I I have to say when I
uh you know in in England for example I
certainly knew people who had you know
their families have been in the same
houses for 400 years and things like
this and they would find junk from 400
years ago that was kind of um uh you
know
un just stuff lying around I I did
remember um uh at some point when we
were had a company touch press that made
um uh iPad ebooks and so on and we had
all sorts of different assets for
different things there was a time when
some folks associated with touch press
were poking around Windsor Castle which
I guess is a thousand years old roughly
um and uh they were uh sort of shown to
some storage area there which really did
have junk that went back you know sort
of throughout the history of of for a
thousand years and um you know probably
when things have been just oh let's put
it here we'll just store it here and
nobody paid attention to it there can be
not such high quality stuff that
survives a long time but by the time
it's passing through many hands
somebody's going to throw it away if
it's junk so to speak and and I suppose
you see the same thing with books for
instance if you say oh but you know back
in the day people were writing such
wonderful books well actually if you go
look at the internet archive or
something and you look at scanned books
where where somebody has scanned sort of
everything that was out there in
1865 something there's a lot of junk
there's a lot of things where it's like
this is a book you look at it it's kind
of um somebody's very ponderous essay on
something uh that says absolutely
nothing and it's just you know pure
fluff um and but yet our impression is
you know there were great books back in
the day and that's primarily because the
Great books survive and get reprinted
the fluff dies out um of course there
will be some good stuff that dies out
because people didn't understand that it
was good at the time when it was sort of
uh soon after the event so to speak and
so you have to kind of uh so it gets
lost and that's why you know I don't
know whether some works from Antiquity
were lost because in the period right
off to let's say the fall of the Roman
Empire people were like ah this isn't
very interesting who cares or you know
the monks who are copying things or
whatever um just were like we don't
happen to care about this or we think
it's shocking or whatever else you know
let's not preserve this and then perhaps
those things get uh get rediscovered and
this is a remarkable thing that sort of
seems to happen with some regularity
that you would think that the past if we
didn't know what happened back then
we'll never know what happened back then
but actually things start showing up you
know somebody will notice that oh by the
way somebody wrote some new thing on the
back of a of a manuscript from uh that
was a copy of something that Archimedes
had done that was a a thing that
happened um maybe what 40 years ago
something like that that was a sort of a
new UN un um I'm trying to remember
there was also a Leonardo one uh that
where that happened but that's a you
know that's a a thing that seems to
happen things seem to show up that one
didn't know were there one example I
know
the Babylonian astronomical Diaries
which were a record Talking of what
records were kept was a record made
every day uh somewhere in uh in the
Babylonian Empire maybe um uh of um uh
of the state of the heavens the weather
the price of grain the height of the
river actually the height of the river
probably tells when it was in Babylon
that this was done because I think there
was a specific River there um that
probably the tigers or Euphrates but I I
should know which one but I don't um the
uh in any case the um the thing that
those astronomical Diaries were made
every day for 700 years and presumably
copies were made of them but what
survives for us today is a couple of
percent of those Diaries but those
Diaries were survived because about 100
years ago people started buying random
Babylonian artifacts from random stores
in places like Paris and London and so
on and they found you know these tablets
were among the tablets that were for
sale there and so it wasn't like
somebody just found a cache of tablets
in some archaeological dig it was these
were assembled through something where
uh where they were very dispersed over
the course of th 3,000 years or you know
more than 2,000 years um and had wound
up as just things that were preserved
because they were kind of cool and then
they had to be reconstructed uh much
later so I think that um the uh you know
this question of of does something end
up being worth more uh because it's old
so to speak you know when it's cool and
it's old then it tends to be worth more
when it's kind of thought to be junk and
it's old maybe it isn't worth more um so
I think that's would be my naive version
of of of of the answer
that let's
see
um gosh many many questions here let's
see if I can just handle some of these
in
um
uh in order Brady asks is there a
connection between Galileo's equivalence
principle and Einstein's equivalence
principle well let's see I mean Galileo
one of his big discoveries about gravity
is that uh you know you drop a um um you
know you drop two different cannonballs
or something made of two different
things made of different materials off
the Leaning Tower of Pisa which was at
that time the tallest building outside
of the pyramids that existed in the
world uh it wasn't um it only the the
Leaning this was not a design objective
the Leaning this was a design mistake um
the uh but it was originally it was just
a a very tall tower um very tall for its
time Tower I think it wasn't until what
was it the Empire State Building in New
York and things um got built that there
were sort of structures that beat the
pyramids and beat the Tower of piser and
so on for for height but I think the um
so Galileo you know happened to be in
Pisa and used that Tower as his
experimental platform I could say quite
literally um and uh was dropping things
and seeing how long it took them to hit
the ground and uh you know discovered
that it didn't matter what the material
was it would still hit the ground at the
same at the same time of course it did
matter if you dropped a feather and uh
you know a lead ball or something they
would hit the ground very different
times because of air resistance for the
feather and famously I think one of the
astronauts on maybe aoll 16 or something
uh brought um uh brought a feather and
some some think else a ball or something
um and drop them on the moon where
there's no uh there's no atmosphere and
sure enough they hit the ground at the
same time and made some some cute
comment about how if this hadn't worked
you know our spacecraft wouldn't have
made it here type thing um but uh you
know this idea that the material doesn't
matter um is kind of the the
generalization of that for Einstein was
not only does the material not matter in
terms of the the pull of gravity you
also can't tell the ex the the extent to
which you can't make a distinction
between a gravitational field the pull
of gravity and the effect of pure
acceleration the purely kind of motion
related effect of acceleration so I
suppose those are things and I think the
the kind of historical progression that
got from one to the other goes through
people like Mark un Mark who was
thinking about kind of what's the origin
of inertia why do things have a mass
well kind of one of the theories that
Mark had was well maybe things have a
mass because they are gravitationally
somehow attracted by everything in the
universe and there were there's a lot of
sort of confusing stuff about rotating
uh you know what if the universe is
rotating there's a there's an effective
force uh kind of the um centrifugal
force that's kind of a a um a force
that's only the result of the fact that
there's motion and so on so a lot of
things there I'm not sure I know the I'm
not sure I've really traced through the
the kind of the detailed history of of
views about sort of what mass is what
inertia is and so on through that period
of time I mean I think uh it's sort of
interesting for me at a meta level you
know we've made a lot of progress in our
physics project and understanding a lot
of these fundamental principles of how
physical Universe gets put together and
what gravity is and all those kinds of
things and it's it's very hard work to
go back and see what were the
antecedence of these ideas you know I
did that for the second law of
Thermodynamics part of the book that I
wrote about the second law recently is a
big effort to kind of untangle the
history of the Second Law which is
really complicated and I uh and I have
to say that I was surprised you know
when I started writing that I was like
well let me see if anybody else has
written this I didn't think they had but
I was looking around and and really
people have written individual pieces
often quite good individual pieces but
not the whole Arc of what had happened
and I think there are several such
historical things that should be done
the whole bunch actually that that sort
of eventually land in things that we
figured out in our physics project and
there are antecedents and it would be
interesting to trace those through I
think it's a complicated trade-off as
far as I'm concerned seeing kind of how
much of one's time I I enjoy doing
history that's why I do live streams
like this and so on but uh somehow I
think the priority has to be sort of
building the future rather than looking
back back at the history although for me
looking back at the history is often
important in building the future uh one
reason for example in the case of the
second world of th an anics was that I
was kind of trying to roll out kind of
my version of how the second law Works
which is a little different than what
people have said before and I wanted to
understand you know am I really right
about what I'm saying I think so um but
to know how to be to feel Justified
saying it's different from what people
have said before before I felt like I
needed to understand why did people what
exactly did people say before and why
did people say it and I think I got very
much to the bottom of that particular
issue but I haven't done that for some
of these other areas um and that would
be interesting to to to
do let
see Epi comments important work from
Bright Minds gets shelved and then we
discover the work decades later and put
it to use have you thought of ways to
reduce this happening so
much look the issue with that tends to
be a different
phenomena one thing that can happen is
the person is just an obscure place and
not well connected to getting the word
out let's put that aside for a second
the more common cases there is something
which somebody discovers but they don't
really have a context for the discovery
that never really gets critical mass the
context that never really is a big story
it's just this particular phenomenon was
discovered and it takes often a long
time for the context of that Discovery
to be clarified and then sometimes what
really happened is somebody discovered
something and then nobody understood
including the person who discovered it
in a broader context at that time and it
took that broader context developing
before you could go back and say well
actually they discovered this good
example of this Moses shfl 1920
something I've studied quite a bit
invented these things called combinators
which are kind of a a symbolic
representation of what we would Now call
computation he thought of it as kind of
an idealized model for mathematics
essentially and for the processes of
mathematics in some way he didn't write
that much about what he really thought
it was well that was 1920 1936 Alan
touring invents touring machines and has
a much clearer enunciation of the idea
of universal computation the idea you
can have one fixed piece of computer
hardware and you can feed it different
programs which will do sort of all
possible different computations looking
back from what we Now understand the
touring machines we can say yes Moses
shfl already discovered Universal
computation but at the time that wasn't
an obvious thing there wasn't really a
context into which to put that idea of
universal
computation now there are other things
that happen we're talking about the
second law of Thermodynamics a kind of a
sad story is the story of Lord boltzman
who uh by the
1860s was talking about how molecules
must exist and they must be the cause of
things that we see in the properties of
gases and thermodynamics and so on he
somewhat overclaimed in some ways sort
of oh you can prove the second law must
work based on thinking about molecules
but uh by
1905 bolts had sort of given up people
in fact Ernst Mark was one of the people
who argued strongly against molecules he
said matter is not discret there are no
molecules and that was around well the
last decade probably the 1800s and so on
and um it was uh so it was kind of the
um you know it seems that molecules
don't exist well uh you know boltzman
who who became something of a
philosopher a professional philosopher
professor of philosophy in his lat years
after having been kind of a really a
card carrying theoretical physicist to
much of his life but he has a a place
where he talks about you know one man
cannot withstand the tide of History um
you know I'm going to write down he
wrote One sort of last book about the
molecular theory of gases saying you
know I'm writing this down so that um uh
you know sometime in the future uh you
know when people ReDiscover this not too
much of what was figured out will have
been lost it was a very bad luck I mean
boltzman ended up uh uh well actually
killed himself in
1906 um you know sometimes it's sort of
uh presented as because people didn't
believe in his theories that that's
really not what happened he he he was uh
well in those days what was called
neurasthenia um uh kind of a you know
what would be diagnosed differently as
as some kind of uh bipolar thing in
modern modern psychiatric practice and
so on um it was I don't think it could
be I don't think that the um uh
boltzman's um uh problems can be
attributed to uh sort of the the fact
that the
physicists uh you know didn't believe in
the mular theory I mean boltzman
actually was quite a quite a cheerful
fellow in many ways so he kind of would
would go through cycles of cheerfulness
and not so cheerfulness he actually year
or two before he died um he had visited
California was a German scientist and um
uh uh he wrote a book called a German
Professor visits
Eldorado um and talks about uh the
Americans and um says I think one of his
nice quotes is um you know I think they
have a bright future even though I've
seen them at their worst doing
calculus um and uh he visited actually
the uh uh Berkeley University of
California in Berkeley um at uh when it
was a very young University um uh just
at the beginning of the 20th century but
any case so he was you know he and he
was pretty pretty certainly his
presentation in his book was pretty
pretty cheerful at that time but anyway
so boltzman is an example of something
where a large body of work was like oh
it's molecular theory nobody cares about
molecular theory he had bad luck because
in 1905 Einstein kind of figured out uh
that Brownian motion uh was something
which could be accounted for and was an
indication of the molecular structure of
matter that had been figured out by
small chowski in 1900 I think as well um
and uh the um in fact brownie in motion
the phenomenon of look down a microscope
see these little grains that come out of
pollen and see the fact that they get
kicked around as we now know by water
molecules but that phenomenon had been
discovered by Robert Brown Maybe by
others in the 1830s I think and nobody
knew what it was and then by 1905 it's
like okay it's
molecules and that sort of proves the
molecular theory which had had a lot of
development with people like boltzman
and um the you know it was it was one of
these things where there wasn't quite
the push to have to believe in it
because there wasn't sort of the ambient
context to do it I can relate a story of
my own history this is
1979 I was writing a paper with a friend
of mine named Rock CB who's a
cosmologist now at University of Chicago
um and uh we writing this paper about um
uh the expansion of the early Universe
the um and the fact that if various
kinds of particle physics phenomena
occurred in the early Universe there
would be effects on the expansion rate
of the early universe and we noticed
that if there was a uh if the universe
sort of super cooled just like if you
you have uh water and you cool it really
below 0 degrees Centigrade at ordinary
pressure um the you know if you cool it
below 0 degrees Centigrade you expect
ice is going to form but actually ice
doesn't form until there are nucleation
sites that cause the the solid to start
building up so in principle you can
super cool water and end up with
something where there hasn't been any
there's there's no ice that's formed um
but when there's ever any sort of
imperfection in the water that becomes a
seed and which ice forms so the uh the
question was in the universe could you
super cool the universe if you could you
get all kinds of interesting effects in
particular you would get exponential
expansion of the universe and all kinds
of things like this well we didn't think
I didn't think that um uh that the
Universe would be super coolable by what
turned out to be 10 or of magnitude to
be a significant effect so we stuffed
this in a footnote we said if the
universe was super cooled by by this
huge amount then you would get
exponential expansion and that would
solve various problems in
cosmology okay put that there a couple
of years later maybe a year later I
forget uh other people came along and
said you know what this idea that you
know you can have this exponential
expansion period the things that it
solves are so important that even though
it seems very implausible that you could
get that kind of super cooling we're
going to make a whole Theory based on it
that became the inflationary model of of
early cosmology so to speak I think in
the end in our physics project that all
gets sort of washed away as we see the
Dynamics of Dimension change in the
early universe and so on but that's a
different story the point there was that
that was a phenomenon that yes one could
see the phenomenon yes we could you know
plant a flag and say yes we we
discovered that scenario but we didn't
make the kind of noise about it that
subsequently got made and that made
people sort of forget the fact that
there were these horrendous assumptions
that were being made and say yes this is
important we're going to build a theory
around that and that's not an uncommon
thing to see happen I mean in my own
work uh looking at kind of how simple
rules in the computational universe
produce complicated Behavior having
discovered that phenomenon in things
like rule 30 and so on one can go back
and see the sort of signs of that
phenomenon all over the place I mean for
example John ven inventor of Ven
diagrams had a book in um oh in the
1850s maybe where he wanted to show a
random walk it was the first drawing of
a random walk one knows about and what
did he use to make the randomness in the
random walk he used the digits of pi and
the digits of P are very much the same
kind of story as something like rule 30
there's a rule but yet it makes apparent
Randomness he didn't really comment on
that uh people realized that there was
sort of apparent Randomness in the
distri distribution of prime numbers but
they mostly commented on the
regularities that were sort of
mathematically accessible there wasn't
really a framework for thinking about
complicated things and thinking that
complexity as a phenomenon was something
worth studying and so that was something
well I I had the fun of of figuring that
out um but that was a thing which needed
that kind of context and that's you know
the fact that it needs this big chunk of
context is what led me to eventually
make this big book called the new kind
of science
that is about the context needed to
understand the science around what you
see in the computational universe and
that's you know that 12200 pages is The
chunk of context that I think you need
to get an idea of what's going on there
even even that was not enough for many
people well some people at least um I
think over the years that's tended to be
something which people have felt yes it
really does communicate what it wanted
to communicate which is nice to see even
though it takes a few years for it to be
to be realized I mean I know in the
preface to new kind of science I I say
right there I say you know as of right
now people will find a lot of the things
in this book surprising and hard to
believe eventually in time they will
come to seem obvious and you know
20 two 22 years later now 21 and a half
years later uh we're definitely on the
the uh you know we're rolling down the
obviousness curve to some younger people
like some people who've worked on our
physics project many of the phenomena in
in nks New Kind of Science like
computational irreducibility are like
it's obvious of course it's got to work
that way and uh but you know for people
coming into that uh from the other side
so to speak not having grown up with
these ideas it's like how can that work
how can it be that way that's a very
common
phenomenon I think this question about
how to sort of prevent things which were
worth discovering uh you know how do you
I think bringing
discoveries uh that need
context sort of highlighting this is
really hard I mean you you just have to
I suppose the best thing I can say about
this is that when I
see things discoveries get made in
science there are many incremental
discoveries that do not need conceptual
development they are particular
experiment a particular technical
Innovation these kinds of things they
are a discovery where the overall
Concepts don't have to be redefined it
is merely and now we know there's a
higher temperature superconductor and
now we know there's a particular
biological signaling pathway or
something like this um but the
conceptual framework is the same I mean
I see the same thing with language
design in in wol from language there are
things where there is a conceptual
framework for mathematical functions
let's say oh we've got another
mathematical function it's the Appel F2
function or something there's a
conceptual framework we're just wheeling
in another function that fits into that
conceptual framework and then there are
things that really require new
conceptual development and that's
happened a whole bunch with our physics
project and with the ruad and other
things like this they're really new
conceptual development and I think that
for many people in science that's very
unusual it's it's almost unheard of that
you know people can go through their
whole career with not much change of the
conceptual framework and you know I I
noticed this I was realizing this
recently as I was thinking about you
know podcasts I've done and things like
this and and it's like well I do ones
with like physicists I do ones with
philosophers and I and also you know
when I've uh talked to groups of people
and things uh it's it's sort of
interesting because the the the the
physical scientists often are like they
are used to technical complexity they're
not used to conceptual complexity or
conceptual change and they get very
confused by it it's like but aren't you
saying something which is conceptually
the same as has been said before well no
actually you know it's like well it must
be conceptually the same even though
it's technically different well no
actually whereas for the philosophy folk
it's much more uh par of the course that
one has something conceptually different
because their world is about sort of
conceptual change so to speak so I think
that's a you know the the willingness to
kind of Embrace conceptual change is I
think the that that's probably the
number one thing that affects whether
sort of discoveries that were made ahead
of their time get recognized and and
sort of integrated into the mainstream
is can one sort of break through this
kind of conceptual uh this new paradigm
type thing and and I think that sort of
the learning new paradigms thing is hard
for everybody it's um uh I think that
the the willingness to embrace new
paradigms is uh that's the thing you
have to look for and for example as
science gets more institutionalized it
becomes more difficult to accept new
paradigms because it's like well we've
got you know every biology paper must
have a this or this or this or this or
this oh whoops it's theoretical biology
that doesn't work that way well wait a
minute how do we deal with that we don't
have a way to deal with that uh you know
we don't have a the same value system of
did you do did you do a double blind
clinical Tri
that's not really relevant if what
you're doing is a computer experiment um
you could apply that methodology but it
would be silly um so you know a kind of
a field which has developed to the point
where it's heavily institutionalized and
and where its Paradigm is
institutionalized where in a sense it's
kind of like every paper has to hit the
this this this this this of the Paradigm
that's kind of how you prevent the
possibility how you how you end up with
submerging things that require new
paradigm to understand them so I I don't
I don't have a great answer to that
but you know I think this this uh this
willingness to accept conceptual change
is something that is important and it it
goes along with the general thing that I
suppose might be a mantra of mine is
kind of learn to think rather than just
learn to to do things in a particular
mechanical
track
well let's see
uh there's a question here from
Giovani about the development of string
theory and whether its Inception was
within
mathematics has it yielded T tangible
technological
advancements so string theory is a is a
bizarre story of scientific
development um let's see if I can get it
right
the
uh
um so after World War II sort of the
physicists who worked on the Manhattan
Project went to populate particle
physics and a bunch of money got
allocated to building particle
accelerators and the result of that was
that lots of you know protons crashing
into protons and so on and producing
lots of particles and one of the
surprises was in the 1950s that there
were more and more particles that were
discovered you know first it was well
the some particles have been discovered
in cosmic rays pons the muon the kons
the Lambda particle the hyp the sigma
particles um these kinds of things but
then there started to be particle
accelerators and there was a whole zoo
of particles soon there were hundreds of
particles this was my uh when I was a
kid uh one of my sort of favorite
all-time favorite books was this little
booklet the um uh little particle
properties booklet I started getting
them back in 1972 when I was 12 years
old um the uh kind of um there was a
summary of the properties of all these
particles you could look through and you
know there was the F meeson with a a
mass of 1270 M and the the a is that
right I think that's right um you know
the A2 mesom with a mass of 12200 is
maybe the r mesom with a mass of 76 M I
think um and uh see this is a this is a
good memory test for me let's see if I
can do some of the others the sigma
particles I think they're 1385 meev the
Lambda particle I remember that one that
was 1115 me although I think it changed
because back when I knew about these
things it was always 1115 meev but now I
looked it up more recently and it's got
four decimal digits after after that and
I think it might have flipped over to
1116 now but in any case whole zoo of
particles it's like what were these
things you know can we understand what's
going on there were um a couple of uh
well there were there were a couple of
hypotheses um but one of the things that
um was uh well there were really two
well okay there
was okay in the history of particle
physics there had been great success in
Quantum Dynamics the theory of the
interactions of electrons with photons
that was making use of quantum field
Theory Quantum field Theory had been
developed in the late 1920s really on
the on the on the on the tale of of the
development of quantum mechanics in
general the idea of how would you
represent not just a single particle in
quantum mechanics but a field where
there can be particles produced and
annihilated and so on and and varying
numbers of particles so that that
development had by the 19 1940s it was a
pretty elaborate mathematical
development the idea of renormalization
which kind of dealt with the Infinities
that developed there and so on came in
and uh andan diagrams got invented as a
calculational method and by the by the
1950s people were calculating away and
you could work out the you know the
precise uh probability for you know
electron to scatter against a positron
or the exact anomalous Magnetic Moment
of the electron things like this you
could do that by calculating by doing
these very elaborate calculations with
fan diagrams with more and more
elaborate diagrams trying to work out
more and more precisely the predictions
of quantum electrodynamics and it worked
really well and there were a bunch of
things discovered which said yes it
agrees with Quantum electrodynamics
we've got a great solution there the
problem was that the calculations of
quantum electrodynamics relied on the
fact that you know you emit a photon you
have another Photon the chance that you
emit two photons is much smaller than
the chance you emit one Photon and
there's a quantity the so called Fine
structure constant value about 1 over
137 denoted Alpha um and roughly the
fine structure constant tells you the
probability to emit another Photon and
so you emit one Photon probability Alpha
emit two photons Alpha squared the three
Alpha cubed and so on so you can make
this kind of power series of how many
photons did you emit
and it's a rapidly the the numerical
contributions at least nominally are
rapidly decreasing okay footnote to that
actually the true formula is that in the
Ki order of So-Cal peration Theory the
the typical contribution in Quantum
electrodynamics is square root of K
factorial times Alpha to the K and so
for large k um actually the the the
prefactor wins and everything blows up
and that's still not well
understood let's put that aside people
didn't pay attention to that back in the
19 1950s when calculations and Quantum
electrodynamics were happening and and
it looked really good looked like you
really calculate things problem was not
everything had the kind of very weak
interaction strength that
electrodynamics has in particular the
strong nuclear force that binds Atomic
nuclei together and that was you know
yukawa ieki yukawa 1935 had suggested
that there was this thing called the pon
which became called the pon which was
the sort of a particle got exchanged the
analog of the photon but a thing that
would bind nuclei together problem was
that the analog of the the alpha being
one over 1137 in Quantum electrodynamics
was at best a a coupling constant as
it's called of order one so you couldn't
really make this series where you say oh
there's one Photon effects two Photon
effects three photons and they they get
progressively smaller it's like
everything was all put together so the
question was how to deal with that and
that was one thing then there was this
kind of zoo of particles being
discovered and there were different
hypotheses so one was let's figure out a
way to do something like field Theory
something like what was done in Quant
electrodynamics for the strong nuclear
force and various kinds of limits of
zero Mass p and things were were studied
uh that led to one branch the other
Branch was
um uh what so-called SM Matrix Theory
where it's like let's not think about
the mechanics of how the interactions
happen
let's just say particles come in
something happens in the middle
particles go out let's just look at the
comparison of what comes in and what
goes out let's just look at the overall
effect of the
interaction that the S Matrix was an
idea that had been introduced by Vera
Heisenberg actually I just recently
leared the origins of the of the SM
Matrix idea which are something I
absolutely didn't expect so Heisenberg
back in the
1920s had been you know quantum
mechanics was in everything looked like
it was being discreet there were all
kinds of uh you know the the uh all
kinds of discrete energy levels in atoms
discrete spin values for particles lots
of discrete stuff and so the Assumption
got made that space would also be
discret and uh that's a thing that you
know in fact it seems like I'm I'm sort
of accumulating the list of people who
thought that I I recently learned that
Neils bore thought that that verer
Heisenberg thought that that space would
be discreet it's sort of ironic because
a big piece of of the origin of our
physics project is the idea that space
is discret which a 100 years later was
completely shocking um until we started
to sort of work through how that how
that really works out but in any case
Heisenberg wanted to make a model of
discrete space and had this kind of
cellular model of discrete space really
kind of interesting I didn't know that
he'd done that until just a few weeks
ago and apparently in the effort to do
that and to make that consistent with
relativity which was very hard to do he
sort of threw up his hands and says
let's not look at the mechanics of how
the particles interact let's just say
how did they come in how did they go out
that led to the SM Matrix idea so then
people had the idea of well let's just
look at the properties of the SM Matrix
we know for example that as we uh kind
of changed the moment of the particles
that are coming in the SM Matrix should
vary the the probability of interaction
should vary as some function of the of
the uh of the momenta it should have be
a function that has certain properties
it should have certain analyticity
certain smoothness properties it should
have certain invariances under so-called
Crossing swapping particles and
antiparticles in the initial and final
States and so on let's just not worry
about what's happening inside let's just
say it's just an S Matrix and it has
certain properties as a mathematical
function so to speak and that was that
was sort of one side of things was the
SM Matrix approach the other side of it
was the field Theory approach let's see
the mechanics of what's inside sort of
in the middle of that was what are the
all these particles do all these
particles have sort of a mechanical
explanation in the end it turned out
they were all made of quarks that was a
thing proposed by Mari Gman and George Z
around
1964 um but uh that was the um and there
had been precursors of that a person
called sakata had had a precursor model
of that a bunch of other precursors to
that but any case the the um the thing
was was kind of are they mechanically
made of stuff or not person called Jeff
Chu in in Berkeley um had kind of the
democratic theory of particles was kind
of a time I suppose this was heading
into the 1960s when there was a big push
for kind of changes in the world order
and the idea that there couldn't be
there shouldn't be a a particle in
charge so to speak a top particle the
idea that there could be sort of a
democracy of particles was was in a
sense ideologically and politically kind
of a a a pleasant thought for the
Berkeley folks of that time and so this
was an idea that sort of all particles
were were equal and it was kind of this
this notion of the bootstrap where you
would have a um different and quite
different from the bootstrap and
statistics that's something quite quite
different came much later um this was an
idea where you would say well you could
think about you know particles you could
think about fact you have a particle you
could think about a force that came from
the exchange of particles somehow all
these things were related and when you
put them all together this was sort of
the the the only thing that was
consistent was the particles you would
have okay so that was another piece
another piece to this picture was a chap
called too Reggie who I unfortunately
never met I could easily ad met but I I
never did um a very creative
scientist uh who well had do I don't
know a somewhat complicated trajectory
but um back in the 1950s he invented
these things called Reggie trajectories
and and what he was doing he was
studying uh things like the scattering
of one particle from from something that
scattered it like a particle hitting
being scattered by an atomic nucleus or
something like this and he was asking
the question so in quantum mechanics
there's this quantization of angular
momentum and he asked the question and
so you would have angular momentum J
equals 1 2 3 4 etc etc regie asked the
question well what happens if J is a
complex variable it's a continuously
varying thing what happens to these
so-called scattering amplitudes and that
led him to this idea that for example
you could have a scattering amplitude as
a function of uh momentum that had well
that that where where you looked at this
angular momentum in the comp complex
plane and and that led him to questions
like well maybe all these particles that
we have are just sort of features of a
mathematical function each particle is a
pole a one /x a place where the where
the function blows up when X goes to
zero that they're all sort of poles in a
function and then that you would have
something where you could um and I
should say by the way that the S Matrix
as a mathematical function when there is
is a um when you have the energies of
the incoming particles being aligned
exactly so that you produce just exactly
one of this zoo of particles then the uh
scattering amplitude in the probability
of
interaction uh would be infinite were it
not for the fact that the particle you
produce doesn't live in infinite time so
it is a pole in the S Matrix a an
Infinity in the S Matrix associated with
the production of a single particle if
that single particle lived in infinite
time if it lives only a finite time it
kind of gets smoothed out a bit but any
case so the idea of Reggie poles that
corresponded to these particles led to
these sort of diagrams where you would
plot the mass of the particle against
its it spin it's angular momentum and
you would see that roughly particles lay
on straight lines the particles that
were being discovered lay on straight
lines in these Reggie plots so to speak
so that was a another piece of sort of
the picture that was kind of on the SM
Matrix side okay so into all of that
came um I'm trying to remember the the
the order in which all this stuff
happened the
um
uh there was a a particular the the a
particular form of of mathematical
function that was sort of a convenient
version of the S Matrix that had a
convenient mathematical form involving
uh gamma functions beta functions things
like this um that
had
gosh I lived through this history I
should remember this stuff it was due to
a person called Gabriel veneziano um who
invented this particular form of the of
the SM Matrix um and
uh uh let me
think there was an the whole point was
that there was an interpretation of that
in terms of
strings what is a string well in
standard quantum mechanics and
particularly in relativistic quantum
mechanics you're always talking about
particles you're talking about a point
particle like there are equations like
the dur equation is the equation for a
point particle like an electron with
spin a half and there are these various
equations that describe Point particles
and when you think about a point
particle and what it does it has a world
line in space time it it the particle
can move and you you kind of Trace out
its its World line in in space time and
it's it's just a line okay so people
have been interested in well how do you
generalize that even sort of at a
mathematical level how do you generalize
that to a world sheet where you have a
whole string that is moving through
SpaceTime moving through through space
in in time and one thing that was true
about partical was that the um uh you
could Define kind of what what world
line a particle would make using a uh an
principle of least action using a kind
of optimization principle the particle
will follow the trajectory that
corresponds to the path of least action
and so you could imagine generalizing
that to this extended object and its
World sheet instead of the world line
has a particular form the world sheet
has to have a particular form now I'm
I'm trying to remember the um uh and I'm
sorry I'm this is this is what happens
when I get close to a piece of history
that perhaps it's harder to disentangle
it um the uh The veto amplitude the the
form of the um uh of
um uh of the S Matrix that had an
interpretation in terms of of strings
and then this idea of sort of this
physical uh layout of strings
propagating through through SpaceTime um
and I remember when I was you see this
is fragmentary memory I'm Afra
when I was um probably this is 1975 I
was 15 years old I happened to visit um
a physics group in Cambridge England and
uh a couple of the people there were
working on what became string theory and
I remember they were explaining to me
this thing about world sheets and the
and the minimization of of some analog
of the action for world sheets so that
must have already been a thing by
1975 um the uh those were sort of the
leading people some of the leading
people who invented that stuff so maybe
it wasn't totally old by that time might
be 6 months old or something but um the
uh uh in any case the the original idea
of string theory was it was part of a
theory of strong interactions and it
came out of this kind of very
mathematical construction and it was it
was something that was supposed to be
kind of a a um uh a way of thinking
about the S Matrix which would be a way
of thinking about strong interactions
and the kinds of processes that happen
in Ai and um
then oh it got very confusing because in
1973 the discovery of astoic Freedom
this is the property of of quantum
keramics the theory of quarks and gluons
that if you kind of Kick the Quark hard
enough it will its effective value of
alpha alpha subs for the strong
interaction will be low enough that you
can use pertubation theory that you can
use this this series expansion thing
that and that was so when you you have
interactions which are which kick in
hard enough so-called deep in elastic
scattering where you have particles that
are very inelastic in their scattering
they don't just bounce off they kind of
Bounce at a big angle and they um uh
they kind of a lot of momentum is
transferred in those cases the effective
uh interaction strength is lower and
that means that you can use quantum
field Theory you can use all the
apparatus of quantum field Theory and
that was a thing that was discovered in
1973 and really sort of turned the tide
of quantum field Theory versus the SM
Matrix approach this mechanistic Quantum
field theory of how strong interactions
worked at least at at at high momentum
transfer high energy um was something
that then really took off it was
something I was much involved in and the
a few years after that um but uh the um
uh the thing that um but that was sort
of a discovery made in 1973 and um uh
after that time kind of the the fate of
the SM Matrix and and kind of that
approach to things it sort of degraded
and and quite rapidly you know particle
physics was at that time a really sort
of a very energetic field uh full of the
best and the brightest so to speak um
but the best and the brightest
definitely as a her rushed off to
whatever seemed like the the brightest
thing and that wasn't SM Matrix Theory
so that died very quickly at that time
after the discovery of asmic freedom and
you know somewhat confusingly even in
qcd the the idea that when you pull
quarks far enough apart they would have
kind of this string of gluonic stuff
between them that was kind of a
confusing thing that was sort of a
little bit like strings but it wasn't
the same kind of strings but it sort of
was but it wasn't mathematically the
same all a bit messy there okay so that
was thing number one was strings as a
mathematical theory of the strong
interactions and so on and that kind of
died off by the by the
1970s um and uh uh that was yeah so I
mean I
think um but except as kind of a
mathematical thing like studying world
sheets and so
on okay
then what happened next the
um uh by the late
1970s there was kind of a a rebirth of
this in the form of of um uh that came
out of super gravity boy this is a this
is a really Shaggy Dog story um I mean
String Theory got re sort of uh retooled
multiple times for multiple purposes and
uh kind of as a as a theory of gravity
um something which sort of would would
be a theory that would sort of where the
the vibrations of the string would
correspond to all possible particles and
Cor respond to effects of gravity but
that was only consistent if the the
whole Theory kind of fell apart unless
the strings were in either 10 Dimensions
or 26 Dimensions which isn't what we
observe in physical space and then that
was sort of explained in terms of well
the extra dimensions are curled up very
small and we don't we don't detect those
and uh then that led to a bunch of
development of uh kind of the
expectation that there will be a bunch
of particles that would be additional
particles the super partners of of
existing particles and those weren't
discovered and so that was kind of a
downer for that and what's sort of
ironic is that the ideas of smatrix
theory are back in there's the thing
called the conformal bootstrap which is
very similar to the in fact it's the
same thing as the original bootstrap
idea that was part of the Democracy of
particles back in the 1950s and so on
and the mathematics is all the same and
so things are sort of coming back back
along those lines so I I mean I could
fill in more of this history but I think
it's it's ornate and it's going to take
me a little while to it takes actually
describing some of the physics of what's
going on to see how this stuff this
stuff works and maybe we shouldn't do
that right right now but but um the I
mean in terms of kind of what's
happened
well okay this question of sort of how
do you make string theory the theory of
kind of you know build sheets and all
that kind of thing how do you make that
kind of thing consistent turned out to
be pretty hard and that's what led to
this 10 Dimensions 26 Dimensions
otherwise you get sort of Wiggles on the
string that go faster than the speed of
light and other other sort of
pathologies unless you have those
conditions and then as one added sort of
more internal symmetries to the strings
and so on it was kind of like well we
can kind of get these different
situations in which we get different
kinds of theories and eventually there
was things called M Theory that
developed in the 1990s I guess that was
kind of the ultimate sort of put in all
the symmetries put in all the conditions
it's the ultimate kind of unified thing
that is kind of a representation of of
uh uh of string theory and that that was
um uh that looked like oh it's so it's
so pretty that it must be the theory of
how it must be how physics actually
works but it hasn't you know that hasn't
been hasn't been possible to of show
that that's the case my guess is that
there is a a strong a way of thinking
about String Theory as a limit of the
models that we've developed um and and
roughly the way that would work is in
our models I'm okay physics moment here
in our models uh kind of there's this
giant graph hypergraph that represents
the structure of space and one of the
things that's notable is there just this
big graph and you go from one node in
the graph to another node in the graph
and you can think about yourself as as
moving physically in physical space as
you do that but also it's possible that
what's happening is that as you move
from one node to the graph to another
you're you're sort of moving in some
internal space it's like in the case of
qcd one thinks about there being a color
space where the the uh particles can be
sort of red green blue not really red
green blue but that's just a an analogy
for mathematics um but really there's
some angle that's an internal degree of
freedom of the particles and something
internal to the particles an internal
feature of particles and in our models
all of that stuff has to be encoded in
this graph so as you move from one node
to another you can be either moving in
physical space or you can be moving
effectively in the internal space of
these properties like color of these
particles and so teasing apart what
corresponds to physical space What
corresponds to this internal space
that's not an easy thing we've been
trying to do that and understand how to
do that but my guess is that there will
be particular ways of sort of factoring
the physical space and the internal
space that will be particularly elegant
cases that will probably correspond to
string theory and whether that's you
might say well that's a you know these
isolated elegant cases they're probably
not what actually happens but it's
useful to be able to see those cases as
kind of versions of the model that you
can explore in more
detail
let's see all right let me just have a
quick look here
um oh my I got to go soon
uh let's
see
um I see a comment here about some uh
going back to the question about why are
some old things uh gain and value the
comment being that some old things are
worth more due to Nostalgia eventually
it will lose its value again it's sort
of interesting isn't it I mean the you
know for example Egyptian Antiquities
were not really such a big thing people
just had pieces of you know giant Stones
lying around and so on and then folks
like Napoleon were like this is really
cool you know we're really establishing
ourselves as as uh sort of important
Empress for the ages Type Thing by
having our Egyptian you know Antiquities
uh you know hauled into our Central
Square type thing and you know as a
question of of do these things actually
go down in in importance again is there
a is there a moment when history is
forgotten and clearly there are some uh
cultural and political ideologies where
sort of the the the idea is history is
irrelevant you know let's start aesh
we're going to invent things that are
going going to be the kind of the um uh
the great thing going forward history be
damned so to speak and it does seem to
be a feature that you do see these
cycles of you know oh you know let's
make the new yes we're going to make
figure out all this stuff you know um uh
the quotes This Time It's Different
motto um and uh you know we can forget
everything that happened before I would
say that the the main lesson of history
is that there are lessons of History so
to speak
that is that perhaps it's because we're
still the same species with the same
human characteristics perhaps it's just
because there are certain necessary
features to uh to sort of how things
build on other things sort of causal
connections between things that lead
history to have some degree of
repetition I mean it's of course the
meta question of history is is there a
theory of History are there things that
you can sort of
formalize and say historical progression
has to work this way I mean people will
say things like you know when an Empire
gets welldeveloped it gets giant
bureaucracies and eventually it falls
over in its own inefficiency so to speak
you know people say that I don't know if
that's really true as a trend across all
of history but there certainly are
things where where you see certain kinds
of repeating patterns and you know to
say there's a theory of history in part
it's like well let's take these
particular repeating patterns and say do
we see these and then on another side
let's say are is there a predictive
theory of History uh kind of like azimov
psycho history idea where which I mean
my principle of computational uh
equivalence and and uh computational
irreducibility kind of denies the
possibility of that in the end but there
might still be some pockets of
predictability in history if it works
this way then this is how it must come
out in a sense quantitative Finance
tends to be all about finding those
those pockets of predictability in
history so we know there is some of that
um it's uh
uh uh gosh people people commenting here
about um my recent efforts in what I'm
calling Observer Theory and uh
uh oh gosh all right this is this is one
that um
um
uh oh lots and lots of interesting
question questions here there's a
question about the history of Observer
Theory uh yeah um it's long and
complicated and full of
philosophy and I don't know it and it's
a significant amount of work to track it
down I mean I I am certain that from
Plato and his cave to deart and his uh
kind of views of I think therefore I am
and so on to uh more modern kind of uh
versions of of whether it's in control
theory or or systems engineering where
you actually have the notion of
observers and measuring devices and so
on that are sort of part of the the
theoretical framework there are just
many many many places where this kind of
overall idea of making a theory of
observers has come up the kind of
particular knitting together that I've
tried to do I think has not been
possible before because one hasn't had
these kind of this overall framework
that's come out of our physics project
and the ruad and so on that lets one
kind of paint this bigger picture but I
think there are antecedants of of what
I've tried to do in observer Theory
there are lots of antecedants and really
piecing those together would be very
interesting it's a lot of work and I
think some of it will be in a sense back
projected history that is now we can see
with some clarity what's going on we can
project back and say well deart was more
or less saying this if we translate the
Latin the right way and kind of you know
uh and we try and project back into his
context very different from our context
um uh you know I think it's interesting
to see this and I think there will be
probably some insights that will come
from understanding that history
certainly will be useful in terms of
seeing you know how does it relate to
various kinds of Eastern strands of
thought as opposed to Western strands of
thought these kinds of things those are
those are really interesting questions
which as I say I have not taken the
extra few months to try to dig into that
um in fact in general I would say that
sort of for me I'm sort of hoping other
people and some people are picking this
up of looking at the sort of
philosophical implications and the
historical philosophical implications of
a bunch of the things that we're doing
in our physics project and so on um I
think those are very interesting and
they really help to to provide context
for what we're doing um but it's a lot
of work you know as I say I just did it
for the second La of thermodynamics and
it was a lot of work there and I think
some of these other things are perhaps a
bit more difficult than that because in
that case there's sort of a a a a
mathematical result that one is aiming
for in the case of something like
Observer Theory the question of kind of
what one is uh you know how does one
understand this notion of you know the
complexity of the world being projected
onto a mind and of the things that many
things have been said about that the
particular kind of way of understanding
that that I developed as I say is very
much born of of modern paradigms in the
physics project and so on but but seeing
how that relates to things that people
have thought about about that before is
is very interesting and I just haven't
done it so uh all right I think I better
go back to the day job here um but uh
thank you all for um uh giving me a
chance to think a bit about history and
um I look forward to going on another
time I think um if we look at the
schedule here well we're about to run
into the holiday period um and uh uh we
may miss a few of these but um uh I'll
be um uh for me these are these are I
will be trying to do them as much as I
can all right thanks for joining me see
you another
time
that